hey guys and welcome to
a video or rather a series of videos
that i'm really really looking forward
to making
so uh this is going to be
a new series of videos on
two
uh topics within the realm of chess
improvement
and these are two very broad topics that
i think do not get enough coverage
um on youtube and on twitch and chess
literature
and as i'll explain the second issue i
have with these topics is that when they
are tackled i think that it's not done
in a manner that's particularly
systematic or conducive to mastery and
i'm going to try to
take on the very ambitious task of
rectifying that
and these two topics are principles of
the endgame
and principles of positional play or
just positional positional play
positional concepts so over the course
of the next couple of months i'm going
to make a bunch of these videos on what
i believe to be the most important
endgame principles and themes and the
most important principles and themes
within the realm of positional chess so
today we're talking about king activity
but uh we're going to try to cover as
many important concepts as possible
we're going to talk about weak squares
pawn structure
maneuvers all of those nitty gritty
impositional chests and end games that
you might be fearing or you might think
only gms kind of can do i'm going to try
to demystify and present in a relatively
coherent manner
now the big thing that i'm going to be
doing
and this is really the guiding method
behind these videos that rather than
focusing on just one example and
spending 30 minutes on it i'm going to
try to go
uh i'm going to try to go for breadth
here i'm going to show at the very least
four to five examples per video because
i believe that much like tactics it's
not enough uh to show somebody what a
pin is right you then have to give that
person five or six examples at a minimum
uh so that they can see the various
manifestations uh you know and what to
look for it's not enough just to explain
you also have to drill it down and
that's what i'm going to be trying to do
with positional chests and with end
games i feel like
they can be learned in a very similar
manner to tactical themes
and that is by looking at several
examples all at once and uh really
getting that pattern recognition in
place as early as possible so
with that ambitious goal in mind let's
begin
and today we're going to start with what
is perhaps the single most important
principle of the end game
which is king activity you must keep
your king active at all costs in the
vast majority of end game positions
and uh
we are going to take a look at what
exactly that even means and we have some
fascinating end games ahead of us the
last thing i'll say before we jump in
uh and i won't be making this uh you
know long-winded introduction and
subsequent videos on these topics
uh but i will be going relatively fast
on all of these examples so feel free to
pause the video
uh you know set this up on your own
board again i'm gonna try to fit five
examples within 30 minutes so uh there
there will be moments within these games
where i'm not focusing on interesting
stuff just because it's beyond the
purview of what we're talking about but
that doesn't mean you can't explore
things and you can't learn from
from these games in ways other than as
an illustration of of the topic so
so by all means feel free to structure
this in the way that is most conducive
to your learning
and let's start with a
classic example that i showed all of my
students i feel like everybody should
know it because it is perhaps the single
most clear illustration of how much king
activity changes the landscape of an end
game this is a game between
uh cuban world champion jose raul
capoblanca
uh fourth world champion and severely
tartar cower who was one of the
strongest players of the early 20th
century i believe he was uh later given
the grand master title by fiji toward
the end of his life
and uh kappa blanc and tardikar have
reached a really interesting endgame
material is currently equal five pawns
each
uh but you might see that white has this
protected pass pawn on g5 and of course
we will also talk about past pawns in
uh in a subsequent video but if you look
a little bit more carefully you'll see
that there is a bit of a problem white
has this incredibly weak pawn on c3 and
a weak pawn on a4 and that pawn cannot
be defended white's rook although it's
on the seventh rank it cannot return to
defend this pawn it looks like white's
not only going to lose this pawn
but the king is going to be tossed back
to the second rank
and this g pawn alone is not going to
decide the game in white's favor
because
after g6
even the rook can simply capture on g6
and after rook takes c7 rook g7 black is
totally fine
the position is approximately equal
uh what else can white try why could try
to hunt for the d5 pawn but
that kind of loses focus rook takes c3
king e2 black can defend it with c6
and if white pushes g6 that doesn't do
as much as it seems to because after
rook g3 the rook is behind the passport
at the very least
black's position is very comfortable the
game should end in a draw
but it turns out that in this position
white is winning with an absolutely
brilliant maneuver one of my favorite
and game maneuvers
capablanca realized that these pawns do
not matter
the only thing that matters is the fact
that after black takes on c3 white's
king is going to be tossed back to the
second rank and that cannot be allowed
capoblanca thought about it and realized
the king actually has a pathway
toward black side of the position where
he can support this crucial pass pawn on
g5 capoblanca plays the move king g3
tardo coward takes on c3 and the king
turns the corner king h4
the whole point here is that the king is
going to walk up through h5 to g6 or
through an alternate path that i'm about
to reveal and once the king gets into
black side of the board it's going to be
so much easier to push this pawn white's
king rook and pawn are going to
overwhelm black stroke because black's
king unlike its counterpart is
completely cut off along the eighth ring
watch what happens tartakower continues
to go after white's pawns
now king h5 was possible but capoblanca
finds an even more efficient way of
getting the king straight into the heart
of black's position the king diagonally
whoops apologies for that the king
diagonally crosses its way to f6
target coward can take all the pawns
that he wants he does he takes on f4 he
can even take the pawn on d4 but as my
good friend robert has says it's not
about the quantity of the pass pawns
it's only about the quality you can have
a single pass pawn but that pass pawn
decides the game after king f6 you're
threatening mate
the rook swings over and now checkmate
is simply unstoppable we're not even
talking about promotion here we're
talking about mate
so tardikower instead of taking on d4 he
goes rookie e4 tries to keep the rook on
an open file kappa blanca slides into f6
threatening mate
rook g7 check forcing black's king on to
an awkward spot now capoblanca simply
starts collecting all of black's pawns
rook c8 is a maid threat the king
collects the pawn on f5
goes back to f6 in order to keep
blackstroke passive rooksya made us
there and look at how much mileage white
is squeezing out of that king after rook
at 4 check the king goes on to greener
pastures goes on to e5 in order to
collect the d5 pawn
g7 check another
very nice move by jose capoblanca
one of the great things about having
your king active in the end game is that
almost all pawn end games are going to
be winning when there is such a
disparity in king activity normally if
black's king was on b4 or d7 the game
would end in a draw but because white's
king is so active this end game is an
elementary win the simplest way to win
simply being to slide the king over to
b7 and win all of black's pawns it's
like watching lionel messi on the soccer
field you feel like the king was on f6
one second and it's on b7 the other
target counter can't take the pawn and
campablanca completes the job by taking
two more of black's pawns
and
winning by promoting the d-pawn
tardicara could have resigned a little
bit earlier he resigned here because the
d-pawn is entirely unstoppable a
relatively simple example but
nonetheless this shows the incredible
power how much activating your king in
almost any type of end game can totally
transform the landscape of the position
moving on
moving on
we have the following
position from akiba rubenstein's game
akiba rubenstein also an early 20th
century player uh and one of the
greatest endgame players of that
generation of that time this is also a
relatively famous game now it's black to
play white has just played the move rook
to c1 offering a rook trade
and
a quick look reveals that black really
cannot refuse that trade because if
black goes down to h4 white's rook
infiltrates to c7 and all of black's
pawns fall so rubenstein takes on c1 and
the king takes now you might notice that
there is a disparity in the pawn
structure black's pawn structure is so
much better than whites but
in a pawn end game pawn structure might
not matter because the position could
get locked up and then the game ends in
a draw now the advice that you often get
in these types of positions is to go
toward the center but very importantly
what this game reveals is that king
activity does not just mean going
blindly toward the center of the board
in any kind of end game it means very
mindfully and very carefully charting
the right path for the king the king is
capable of great things but you have to
know where you're going and why if you
go toward the center you're not going to
get much done because white's king is
right in time to stop the infiltration
to c4 and
even though white's pawns are weak
there's nothing to attack them so
instead of going toward the center
rubenstein realized that the target
square for black's king is on h3 and
that is because this pawn on h2 is
white's biggest weakness and what
happens in the game is that rubenstein
makes a b-line straight for that square
white's king barely barely manages to
reach g1 but it doesn't matter again
look at the disparity in king activity
that disparity is transformed into a
very confident win
with a relatively simple but nonetheless
very nice plan rubenstein now realizes
that what he needs to do is clear
kind of you know it's like when you're
walking with an axe and clearing all the
trees he will have to get his king over
to g3
what does that entail well that means
he'll have to trade the pawns on h2 and
f2 and he has just the tools to do that
because white is totally paralyzed first
he goes e5 freezing white spawns
now he goes b5 not strictly necessary
but he wanted to make sure that white
doesn't have any extra moves on the
other side boom boom boom all pawns of
the fourth ring g4 there goes one pawn
okay cone goes e4 trying to mix things
up
obviously g takes f3 would be very
inadvisable always got to be careful
rubenstein plays f takes e4 and now he
plays h4 and g3 the game is over
white is essentially forced to trade
both of these pawns
and after hg3 hg3 eric cohn resigned
because if he takes on g3 then the king
takes walks up to f3 takes this pawn and
the game is over
if white tries
uh f3 then black can win either with g2
or with a6 but the move g2 is probably
the simplest one f4
it looks like white's broken through and
white's promoted but again all because
of the king activity this is not to be
feared king g3 e6 and now a very typical
mating sequence funnily enough black
could even troll with a move like a6
even let white promote and if this is in
an illustration of the importance of
king activity then i don't know what is
so once again
it's all about charting the right path
particularly in pawn end games do not go
blindly toward the center try to find
the right target square for your king
and get the most mileage out of it and
speaking of mileage
let's take a look at one of my games
um from right about 12 years ago against
benjamin bach we would neither of us
were grandmasters at the time this game
was played
but i think this is also good
illustration of the fact that even in
queen end games even when your opponent
has
uh has
an active queen it doesn't matter the
king can overpower even the queen in the
right kind of situation
okay so we have a queen endgame
materials equal six pawns apiece
but if you look carefully at the pawn
structure you might notice two things
first is that black has this very weak
backward pawn on f6 and it's fixed by
the pawn on e4
now that might not matter because white
doesn't have any pieces left but that's
something to keep in mind the second
thing perhaps even more important is
that we have the potential to create a
pass pawn with h4 and i was very tempted
to play h4 here why didn't i do that
because after the trade
black screen swings back to the
blockading post on h6 and white simply
cannot make any progress without
allowing black
to create a pass pawn of his own with f5
so if we go h5
we yield the g5 square black goes f5 and
the pass pawns kind of canceled each
other out there's going to be perpetual
check the king is simply not able to
escape the queen's checks and black can
even push
his pawn if he's so inclined
uh if we don't go h5 we go king h3 then
the queen can just for example park
itself on f4 f5 is threatened if you try
queen g4 obviously black will not trade
black will simply continue checking
white is unable to make progress here
so with that
without uh
eliminated i started to kind of get
scared i thought well i've got this
advantage i've got this advantage but
maybe that can be transformed into
anything and then i remembered something
i remember that my king actually had
legs i don't need to keep it on g2 nor
do i need to hurry with the move h4
i can't use my queen to attack f6
because the queen is guarding this very
important d2 square we do not want to
allow this or rather queen c2 is more
accurate we do not want to allow black
to take all of my queenside pawns so
let's keep the queen on e2 let's make
the king work for it boom
boom
boom boom the king all the way to g6 in
four moves there was nothing black could
have done to stop it
and this makes all the difference i slid
it all the way up to g7 and now when i
move my queen to the f-file the f-pawn
is immediately going to be under attack
plus if i ever push my h-bond which
happens very soon
i call this kind of rolling out the red
carpet once the pawn reaches h6 the king
will be able to supervise the pawn's
progress all the way to promotion which
frees up the white queen to do stuff
like block checks or cover important
squares or attack the f6 pawn or all
three of them benjamin tries to
desperately prevent me from getting a
pass pawn he plays g4 that's an
ingenious move queen takes g4 he takes
on h2 but it doesn't matter this pawn on
f6 is what kills black queen okay i went
a4 first uh don't want to give him any
any pawns my king on g7 is a perfectly
safe and be immune from any checks
whatsoever queen d2 queen g6 now white
is threatening uh queen f7 and then
queen takes f6 so benjamin steps aside
of this king of course you don't want to
take on f6 and give up g3 so i played g4
and benjamin goes queen g3 one really
nice illustration of how important king
activity is even in the queen end game
would have happened if black played
queen f4 so what happens here white can
force a queen trade but black can play
the very clever move king e7
and if you look carefully you'll see
that the point is that white cannot take
on f4 black gets an unstoppable pass
pawn
but you might also see the black is
essentially in zugzwa the queen can't
move otherwise you lose f6 they can't
get move because you lose f6 black only
has two moves at his disposal and that
is to push the pawn up to c6 and then up
to c5 all white has to do is wait it out
king g6 c6 king g7 c5 king g6 and
finally black is in zug's wang and black
takes the queen we play g takes f5 this
is king activity at its finest black has
to step aside and give up f6 and lose
so after g4 benjamin went queen g3
queen f5 check king takes f6 and that's
it i've won the pawn and the rest is
very easy we simply promote the spawn
every square along the g file is
protected
and at this point notice that i don't
really care about my queen side pawns
anymore i have judged that my pawn is
sufficiently far advanced that we can
essentially give up all three of these
pawns because we are so close to
promoting
queen a2 queen e6 cutting off the
queen's control of the promotion square
and now the king hides on f8
and then queen f5 if he went queen c5
check after king 8 there are simply no
more check so benjamin checks me from
the other side
king f8
if queen d8 check look at this king f7
and the queen very nicely covers all of
the potential checking squares
we now four queen f5
last attempt by benjamin to pin my pawn
and after king f7 finally black is out
of checks promotion is unstoppable just
one little funny detail a little bit
outside the scope of what we're talking
about benjamin made a couple more moves
in this position i went queen d5 check
and he resigned but can you spot a
really really cute tactic there was
actually a mate in two and it was quite
a beautiful one there was the move queen
c6 check which i saw but i was afraid to
play it i didn't want to spoil the game
i thought maybe i'm hallucinating but
turned out i wasn't this is indeed
checkmate
so that existed but i decided to win the
game in more mundane fashion notice the
king ends the game on g7 it started the
game on g2 it went all the way up and
that did the trick
okay now
so far we've looked at pretty much
balanced uh balanced end games but let's
take a look at how king activity can
actually help you turn around a
completely lost position sometimes
going into a lost endgame is the only
way to save yourself from a checkmating
attack so
i played this game about 10 years ago
against the grandmaster hungarian gm
super fogorashi who played a phenomenal
middle game he was crushing me and i was
forced to give up a piece and get the
game into what seems like a completely
hopeless end game white is literally up
a full night i don't even have a pawn
for it and to to make matters worse
white has this uh protected outside past
pawn so even a pawn end game even if i
gives up the night is still going to be
lost
i was thinking about resigning here but
then i decided i'll try one last little
crazy idea
and that crazy idea involves trying to
run the king up the board as quickly as
possible and use my past d-pawn to
create last-ditch counter-play watch
what happens king d6
okay he brings his knight back out of
the dead i played rook takes h3 at least
taking a single pawn after 98 check came
the important cross servants i think a
lot of people's instinct here would be
to drop back to d7 in order not to give
up the e6 ball which you have to
understand particularly when you're down
material is that king activity is so
much more important than clinging to a
single pawn not always but in this case
it is after king d7 knight g7 white wins
the pawn anyway and the king is uh sort
of stuck in the doldrums so i figured
all right sparta king c5
knight c7 king c4 i don't care knight
takes c6 and now i get to play d4
and something interesting happens my
opponent took a really long time here
and he couldn't come up with a move he
got into severe time pressure
eventually he plays the very inaccurate
move rookie 4 which is tempting
the best move by the way would have been
this pretty interesting maneuver rook d1
forcing me to push the pawn and now back
to e1 the whole point is that this pawn
on d3 stops the king from coming to d3
and if black tries rook h2
white gives a check
and after king d5 another check
and the beautiful point of this is after
king c4 white actually has checked it on
c5 so king activity comes back to bite
black but this is not easy to spot
particularly given that i think my
opponent had already relaxed after
rookie 4 he had completely forgotten
that my rook can start checking him rook
h1 rook h2
he covers with the rook and i come back
to uh h1
and now i'm threatening to move my rook
to b1 and white's not careful then
black's gonna start having winning
chances once i win this pawn on b2 it's
all because my king restricts white's
king and stops it from coming to d3
my opponent having thought for a long
time almost ran out of time
and kind of panicked he decided to
repeat moves
but again it turns out that he could
have essentially reverted to the other
line and played king c1
and after d3 white has this really cool
maneuver with rookie 4 and rookie 5
again but he simply missed it it fell
out of his field of vision you don't
usually look for checkmates in the end
game
and in this way of course it involves
some luck but i was able to salvage this
create this end game down tonight
against the gm it's all because i
decided as a desperate attempt to
activate my king
and not to keep it passive on d7 to try
to cling to my pawns
and
as our final example i want to take a
look at my
all-time favorite example the first one
the capoblanca game is my favorite
illustration of the importance of king
activity but this last game is my
favorite application of
uh the rule that you have to keep your
kang as active as possible in the end
game this is an absolute treat
okay i don't know why it fast forwards
until the end of the game
but don't worry no spoilers were
revealed
now this game was shown to me by my
coach left sahis uh grandmaster who was
playing white
against a mark hebden uh english
grandmaster and this was the world
junior championship in the 1980s so
neither of these players was a gm at the
time this game was played
sakis has played an excellent game
as you can see he is up upon he's got a
protected and extra passer on b4
and what's more he's got complete and
total domination over all sides of the
board black is entirely paralyzed
now if we make a random move for white
you can see the black is just unable to
move the queen can't move because of
queen f6 check
the rook can't move because you drop f7
either with the queen of the bishop
blacks
basically only thing that he could do is
just go back and forth from a7 to b6
uh the king can't even move because
again you'll drop f7
but the frustrating thing is that it's
not enough to get this church you
actually have to win
and winning is hard because we have
opposite colored bishops and this b pawn
isn't able to reach b6 this is a dark
square and black has control over it
okay now are there any tactics bishop
takes f7 was considered by psyches and
if rook takes f7 there's a check on g6
unfortunately black takes the queen and
there are no discoveries no available
discoveries here for white
so he thought and thought and thought
maybe maybe go c4 but then you yield
this really nice outpost for the bishop
eventually has came up with uh really i
don't think i'm overstating the case by
saying that it's one of the most
brilliant
uh end game ideas that i have seen
because it's not the end game yet the
queens are still on the board i would
still classify this as a middle game but
what size realizes is that one of the
weapons at white's disposal is a queen
trade and the way that white can
orchestrate a queen trade potentially is
to play the move bishop c6
and then to play the move queen to d7
now the problem with forcing a queen
trait prematurely
and this is sort of me imitating what
sahis is thinking is that even in an end
game black is quickly going to get the
rook to the open file white stroke on f3
is no longer applying significant
pressure on the f pawn and black has
excellent drawing chances but
what if in this situation the white king
magically teleported its way over let's
say to c6 well that would make all the
difference right because black's pawns
would collapse
but white doesn't have time to get it
there the king doesn't fly and after
rook a8 king e2 you're not even close to
being in time the king has to remain and
defend these pawns
okay so is there any solution to this
problem well the solution as hopefully
you have kind of by now thought about is
to first bring the king over to the
queen side and then to trade queens
literally king f1
king e2 king d3 at this point hebden
probably thought sahis was gonna stop
there but no king c4
okay now here black white has to be a
little bit careful if you go up to b5
you might get a nasty check on b6 so his
kind of reaches the checkpoint in the
video game he drops it back to b3 again
why does threatening queen f6 jack so
the queen must return to e7
first size fixes the pawn structure note
these moves we've seen them a couple of
times today we've seen rubenstein play
b5 sometimes fixing your opponent's
pawns is a good idea taking care of your
future self you never know when it might
be a good idea to prevent black from
playing g4
and now it's back to business king c4
and now
white has time for king b5 this is crazy
and what's crazy about this is there's
no check on b7 hebden gives check on e8
now black also had a very tempting check
rook v8 check and here you see an
amazing line the king walks all the way
up to a6 and after rook b6 king a5 it
turns out that there are no more checks
and black cannot defend the pawn on f7
the king does it all so hepton goes
queenie a track but now we resort back
to the old idea bishop c6
queen d8
king first drops back to c4
and now it's time for queen d7 which
we've already discussed and the dream
has come true after the queen trade the
king walks right up to d5 and overwhelms
black's defense it's just amazing hebden
tries to trade on his own terms he goes
queen e6 check popsicle says thank you
very much he trades everything and again
king activity decides the day because
the king's gonna walk up to a6 and then
white will either promote the pawn or
win all of black's pawns in the center
and on the king side after forcing the
king uh to walk over to the queen side
watch how this unfolds we don't care
about the f2 pawn that pawn doesn't
matter uh
absolutely take it first psa has played
c4 just stopping any kind of d5
shenanigans and now king b7 you do not
allow black's king to reach c7 then it
would be a draw
he pushes the pawn to b6
now it might seem a little bit difficult
to get this king out of the way because
if you go to a7 you're just going to end
up being pinned but all that psy has had
to do is move the bishop back and now
the threat of king c6 is totally
devastating if black continues shuffling
the king goes up to c6
and if black goes king e7 then at the
very least you can just go b7 king c7
and then you can promote winning the
bishop so
hebden tries the last ditch attempt d5
saejis takes it and it's very clear that
he easily stops the pawn with a bishop
on b5 and that's indeed what happens d6
e3 bishop b5
bishop f6 and now a classic case of two
pass spawns kind of overwhelming the
defenses bishop a6 check in whichever
direction you go you either allow the
king to infiltrate or you allow the pawn
to promote if king d8 and b7 and if king
b8 then psychist goes king d7 again
notice that the king is leading you
don't want to go d7 here because then
it's going to be hard to cover the d8
square so you lead with your king you
walk it up to e8 and then you'll be able
to promote the d-pawn have done resigned
in this position
just a tour de force the king does it
all in this game absolute heroic so even
with the queens on the board if you are
anticipating a queen trade i'm not
saying bring your king from e1 to a7 uh
and then get checkmated there you gotta
be very careful about doing that but
notice how even preparing for an endgame
can involve bringing the king to the
right side of the board so to summarize
we took a look at five examples where
king activity decided the game
all right in the first one that's the
capablanca game we understood that it's
not even about
the quantity of past pawns it's about
the quality and in order to see the pass
pawn through to promotion king activity
is often the missing link it's often
worth literally three or more pawns
that's what capoblanca showed in the
second game
we understood that king activity isn't
just about bringing the king to the
center but well sometimes it is but what
you have to do is chart the right path
for the king you have to understand
where the king actually does the most
work and we saw that akiba rubenstein
understood that the king belongs on h3
here which allows these king side pawns
to march forward and crash their white's
defenses
in my game against benjamin bach we saw
the king activity is important even with
queens on the board and it can be that
missing link because it can relieve the
queen
of some duties that it simply cannot
manage i walked my king all the way to
g7 helping me
create the possibility of a past pawn
and putting pressure on f6
then we saw an example where i yes i was
really lucky but i managed to save an
end game a full piece down
by activating my king at all costs and
creating sudden counterplay against
white's passive king and finally the
position we just saw we saw left sides
bringing the king to the queen side into
black territory literally in the middle
game because he understood that an end
game was coming and in that endgame he
would need his king to be active so
uh
hopefully you know even before you watch
the video you probably understood that
king activity was important but i hope
that these examples really sort of bring
out
uh the
just absolute irreplaceability of the
king in the end game so remember to use
the king wisely again don't get
checkmated that's possible in the end
game but i would say that the guiding
principle that is true across all end
games whether it's a pawn end game or a
queen end game even if there are three
or four pieces on the board is that your
king has to be in the right place
because the fewer pieces there are the
less you can afford to have one of your
pieces
just kind of lounging on a beach that's
what the king does most of the game
but the moment you sense that an end
game is near it's time to start thinking
about the king and what it can do that's
our first most important endgame
principle
and i'll see you in the next video